[Music]
senior chinese officials told senior
russian officials in early february
not
to invade ukraine before don't do it i
tell you of the
olympics oh yeah they told her to wait
till afternoon
and they did hollow didn't happen like
the day after almost or like february
20th is when the olympics you're gonna
do it do it later what was the first day
of the invasion uh let's let's
see after the pole vault yeah it was
after it was after so they listened to
china for sure though
it was the 24th so four days later yes
four days after oh the winter olympics i
remember he did that that fake out
remember he was there that one day and
then he waited another day and then
invaded and then steve was like nah
they're not going to do it and they
didn't do it and i was like dude you're
right and then they did the next day and
i was like
you are still right the other day
so is the chinese [ __ ] tight
with putin oh yeah so china and russia
have kind of gotten together over the
past couple of years um they're buds i
heard that they they went to they had us
they had a they had a falling out after
the soviet fell and then they had a
little bit of issues they're like man
you ain't communist anymore what the
[ __ ] dude i thought we were homies i
know but like i lost money i need more
money how come the chinese people don't
have the other accent but you went
straight to the russians
like man you ain't my friend no mo it's
a it's a it's a 70s
black dubbed kung fu chinese man okay
it's the guy from uh
returning the dragon
vladimir you jive turkeys right away
from us man we ain't coming this anymore
he's just quoting a movie yeah
isn't this one of those more like the
the enemy of my enemy is my friend type
thing well we've been sanctioning russia
so much and all these other countries
have too that we force them to go to
other places in order to get like goods
and items that they need i mean china's
like chinese people does business with
everybody though they're like you you
sell crack i don't care you come to my
restaurant everybody's welcome you know
it's like
you don't want me to work with the north
korea i don't care everybody's welcome
to do business in china
[Laughter]
so putin and xi jinping the leader of
china we need a poopoo they met at the
start of the olympics on february the
4th and declared an upgraded no limits
partnership with in which they pledged
to collaborate more against the west hey
you want the collab
i want the collab with no limit yeah
i like that phrase hey are you tired of
america making all the rules
yes i hate it i i just want to sell
petroleum all over the world
[Laughter]
especially germany
damn that's crazy well you know i think
it's about time that we say [ __ ] you
america i do what i want i mean that is
a scary partnership man
you know what's what's scary so the
whole taiwan thing right like for a long
time the u.s was just able to show our
naval power
in the pacific in the pacific and be
like [ __ ] you trying to get the hell out
of this water dude but lately china has
been violating taiwan airspace
and going i think nine planes flew into
it yeah you know what that's like that's
like all right this is out of bounds dog
and you can't be up in here and then
that's like the kid going
[ __ ] poon they're stepping yeah i did
it [ __ ] what you gonna do i did it
that's basically what china's doing
right now isn't that amazing how
childish warfare is it really is right
they're like what you gonna [ __ ] do
huh huh
and then the reason why china can do
this now is because they're uh their
their navy is bigger than ours now uh
by numbers by number but not by
technology and size yet so they have
smaller ships but like you know china's
apocalypse
you know yeah they're always a quantity
game probably not by geographical uh
advantage either no it's just their
coast and then xi jinping xi jinping
recently just after the olympics invited
taiwan to his birthday but then
cancelled on taiwan and said they cannot
come to us don't come over
but they invited all of taiwan's best
friends
and so that's what makes success all of
taiwan's singing
how are you doing what are you doing
and early reports show that taiwan was
pretty upset by it they were upset
because china was like doing it all in
the open they were showing they had a
big party too and then taiwan's just
chilling watching it they're just
chilling and watching yeah well because
it was in the distance they couldn't get
in because it was in the distance we
couldn't get in that's the new form it's
called full mo warfare it's to make fomo
from other countries going i wish i was
invited warfomo yeah
fomo warfare i read that like biden was
trying to rat on russia with
china
and then china just told russia that
died and tried to rat on him or
something yeah so
it's like don't you know that they're
homies what the [ __ ] going on dude i
didn't don't know
we're out on him with what we shared
intelligence with the chinese yeah about
russia what russia was doing yeah what
their moves are gonna be chinese just
picked up the phone and told the
russians exactly what we just told them
wait i thought they told them our uh
strategic military plans
we shared our military plans with china
something like that yeah obviously we we
shared fake news i hope we did god now
we're telling them the real you know
dude it's so [ __ ] up man yeah it's
interesting but it's definitely like joe
was saying it is i mean the uh russian
planes buzz the united states all the
time same [ __ ] like i'm coming in i'm
coming in i'm coming in i'm coming in
but they gotta fly so far to come over
oh alaska yeah you know alaska used to
be russia how many hundred years ago uh
not that long not that long ago yeah not
that long about those times
[Laughter]
i think we might have even bought it
from russia yeah but there's um
there's russian settlements in alaska
yeah so so be paying for it too i'll
tell you that much
on whale
yeah there's like a russian like
orthodox church there and there's like
russian communities the part that sucks
about all these like with the sanctions
and stuff it's the
regular people get hurt the most yeah
like apple pulled the plug nike pull the
plug and there's just all these like
just regular goods people are gonna
starve man yeah it's just these leaders
they have beef but then the people that
really get hurt are just like the
regular everybody just runs out of apple
and nike products did you see that um
that for airbnbs that are in russia like
people from over here or just or from
everywhere in the world are just making
reservations and paying for time like
even though they're not going over there
just to help people out in ukraine
yeah yeah yeah ukraine yeah and russia
and russia really russia too i think so
i'll just help the people or maybe just
no i think people are just trying to
because i saw a video of like
a russian guy pow on the ukraine side
and the ukrainians are actually feeding
him and letting him call his mom because
he's like just crying he's a [ __ ] i'm a
pow now but i just think people across
the world don't want war yeah so when it
comes to just people taking care of
regular ass people yeah ukrainians don't
have beef with russian people it's just
the the political leaders have beef so
everyone's just like dude this [ __ ]
[ __ ] sucks man like how can we take
care of each other yeah like why would
civilians want that it's like gang
fighting in your own neighborhood like
why would you want that [ __ ] yeah
whether ukrainians like do you want your
mommy
what if they're just laughing in the
background while he's talking to his mom
it looks like a little [ __ ]
i know i think it's a it's a human right
like everyone should be able to go on
itunes and buy a jaru single you know
like every single person every single
person and depriving common people of
that jaw rule singles dude apple pay do
you know how convenient that is everyone
should be listening to ja rule ashanti
songs that's the best song russians
right now are paying a forty percent
premium on bitcoin in order to hedge
against the ruble what
the ruble is under a dollar now yeah
because ruble both went down and bitcoin
went up in that country where was it and
where is it now uh it's a 40 so i think
the ruble went down 20 and the the
bitcoin premium was like 20 so it's a 40
change or so i don't know the exact i
know it's a 40 premium how much rubles
did you hold i'm holding it all the way
to the moon dude
you know their stock market's been down
for like five six days now like they
just they just shut it down completely
yeah because one of the things that i
was reading about like how they can win
the war against russia is bankrupting
them
and and they said just like in 10 days
they can bankrupt the country and i was
like damn that sounds really short for a
country that's really it's crazy to
think that our politicians right now are
basically saying like hey russia
we will attack your economy and put your
economy to zero
like how is that not like
scaring the [ __ ] out of people in russia
or scaring the [ __ ] out of the rest of
the world
that our country can do that yeah yeah i
texted my mom and my mom's in taiwan and
i'm like she was planning on coming back
in may i'm like i think you might want
to come back sooner i don't know what
the [ __ ] going on yeah and then she
says her news over there isn't um
as like dramatized so they feel safer
obviously that's what my dad said they
don't want people to freak out or
whatever but at the same time but did
your dad tell you about a national
blackout
no my my mom told me there was a entire
uh the entire country had a blackout
that has never happened before i mean
the whole country
were they like we're saving electricity
because taiwanese people love to save
money so they're like is that what
happened or what i don't know i thought
they're preparing for the economic
crisis that may face them no they're
just like lately you know we've been
wasting so much electricity cut off the
ac okay ukrainians news wasn't that
sensationalized either right before it
happened all i heard a lot of ukrainians
just were like what the [ __ ] overnight
and they said it fully immediately so uh
i was watching this one vlogger dude
he's uh this asian guy from san
francisco i think his name's like johnny
fd right
and then he
he's a travel vlogger and and i watch uh
this other dude bald and bankrupt they
they all go around and um travel all
over like eastern europe and and
whatever
they're actually in ukraine because um i
think they bought an apartment there or
whatever
and then so what he was saying is that
like when you talk to people on the
ground like no one saw this coming and
so yeah there was news about war against
like russia and stuff but then they had
war in what 2014
and then so they're like it's the threat
is always there anyway so it's not like
yeah whatever it's not that scary i
guess to them because they go oh it's
just russia missile attacks in israel
exactly it's always there right so then
so so like
two two three days before the event
invasion he actually was in you know the
states gathering his things going back
to like fill up his apartment or
whatever and then war broke out so it's
really watch interesting watching the
dude just talking about like all the
steps that that was going down and he
said like so
um
everybody outside of ukraine was like
yeah war's gonna break out get the [ __ ]
out of that country but everyone in
ukraine was like nah they're bluffing
so it's it's just depending on you know
the media where you're at who you're
listening to who you're listening to and
then common citizens don't know what the
leaders are actually plotting so i'm
trying to get my [ __ ] mom out but
then if the [ __ ] feng shui doesn't
tell her there's going to be a war she's
not going to [ __ ] listen dude just
functionally you can make that [ __ ] up
it's easy yeah you could tell her dude i
talked to my own feng shui master no
because they always changed the rules
they changed the rules dude that's how
it works when you're older the rules
work for you did you see the pen and
tell her [ __ ] about feng shui she
was so good no dude it's not [ __ ]
that's disrespectful you shouldn't watch
that is funk's way telling you that it's
not [ __ ] right now my feng shui guy
tells me that you're [ __ ] lying dude
and you're full of [ __ ] dude um you know
what's crazy is the standard is for most
governments to not panic their citizens
but america is just [ __ ] different
the media is so responsible that they
just want everyone to go into frenzy so
they sell more [ __ ] it's his own
entity yeah but most sounds like his
conspiracy
but like most countries don't want that
is the fight that's why like even with
ukraine they probably just don't want
people to start freaking out i think we
will freak out if our news goes it's not
a big deal calm down yeah you're like
what
this just in everything's great
just chill everybody just chill we're
cool
because if they ever said that we would
all automatically think the opposite
that's the best thing about it yeah we'd
be like okay now i'm gonna freak out
because that's what they do with every
even with like that's how that's how
it's a red flag when you see all these
[ __ ] asian people getting [ __ ] up
and then the news goes well you know
crime's actually down
crime is that you're just like wait how
the [ __ ] is that happening man crime's
not for me
that response tells you right there wait
why are you doing that the news usually
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you